when we say change lives change
organizations and change the world we
really mean it stanford gsb equips
students to do that
you first have to start by changing
yourself
students are naturally encouraged to
innovate we tend to attract students we
tend to attract faculty
who are not fearful of making mistakes
the fear is much more on missing out on
opportunities the extreme commitment to
i came to change the world i'm going to
change the world
what does that mean my comfort zone
ceases to exist gsb encourages you to
take risks broadens your perspectives on
how to influence how to lead you learn
to be a critical analytical thinker i
understand the global context of
management the research and governance
that we're doing it shows up in sec
discussions is used by companies in
deciding how they design their
compensation programs how they want to
structure their board of directors this
is not a school where we're simply
training leaders for the domestic
economy at the gsb i can leave virtually
the whole world while standing at this
place the film directors bankers and
private equity consultants renowned
leaders from around the world the nobel
prize winner it's really a
transformational experience change lives
change organizations change the world i
just going to a top business school that
everyone was going to be
super competitive with each other it's
not like that at all going through the
leadership curriculum has really helped
build my confidence and my ability to
manage a high performing team i
graduated from stanford business school
in 2002 authentic leadership especially
the way it's used at stanford being
self-reflective self-aware and mission
driven that ability to to see myself and
be true to myself truly like the couple
years i spent stanford business school
have helped shape what i do as a global
leader change lives change organizations
change the world
if there was no extent for graduate
school of business would be no nike it
was in the entrepreneurship class that
frank schallenberger taught that i wrote
the paper that really became the
blueprint for nike
the opening of the night management
center represents a giant leap forward
for the graduate school of business
through curriculum reform we now provide
a very unique management education
experience it is experiential it's
transformative it's individualized
personalized and now we have the
physical facility to put that in
the knight center really demonstrates
teaching and living responsibly with
concerns for sustainable design
this place is so much more than a
physical facility
so here i'm standing on the edge of a
town square next to the arbuckle cafe
that a about a community court
you can walk by at 10 o'clock at night
and you will see students inventing the
future in front of your eyes
everything on campus is within walking
distance of everything else the
university as a whole is a giant
resource to the students the physical
space grounds us enabling the ideas that
are generated here to go way beyond the
walls of the night management center
i'm really interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation energy
clean tech space we're working in
tourism improve private equity combining
business and medicine stanford gsb
believes in the individual's ability
to affect change make a difference in
the lives of you know hundreds millions
of people the cornerstone of our new
campus reads dedicated to the things
that haven't happened yet and the people
who will bring them up and i think that
in a nutshell captures
the essence of the gsb pursue your dream
dream on a world scale i can do whatever
i put my mind to change lives change
organizations and change the world
you